[Musique]
adélaïde hautval ou l'histoire d'une
révolte et héroïque elle né en 1906 en
alsace dans une famille protestante elle
fait de brillantes études et devient
médecin psychiatre en 1942 elle exerce
son métier dans le sud de la france
en zone libre au cours d'un voyage elle
se retrouve à la douane de vierzon pour
y récupérer une valise perdu elle croise
des soldats allemands qui dénigrent la
france est elle bascule en quelques
secondes dans la terrible réalité de son
époque les enfants et les comprend et
elle intervient donc
en allemand et elle a une altercation
alors évidemment ça lui vaut un arrêt
immédiat et l'envoie à la prison de
bourges et puis bon bah les
circonstances font que
elle est donc à la prison depuis le 29
mai quand une femme juive est incarcéré
dans sa cellule qui porte l'étoile jaune
chose qu'elle ne connaissait pas puisque
ça vient d'être institué le 7 juin et
elle est complètement indigné par cette
mesure elle se fabrique une étoile en
papier et les allemands lui disent
puisque vous les défendez vous ne
partagerez leur sort et donc au lieu
d'être libérés comme elle le devait elle
est gardée à bourges et le 15 juillet
elle est transféré au camp de pithiviers
avec une vraie étoile jaune et un
bandeau ami des juifs
adélaïde hautval est interné à
pithiviers au moment de la rafle du vel
d'hiv
près de la moitié des seize mille juifs
arrêtés transitent par les camps du
loiret est lent soigne beaucoup et son
dévouement lui vaut une déportation à
auschwitz birkenau où sa détermination
ne faiblit pas donc il s'est agi de se
soigner les 400 à 500 femmes koba et
juive enfermé sa elle l'a fait puis
quand on veut lui faire participer aux
expériences qui consiste à retirer les
ovaires dans des conditions
épouvantables à des femmes qu'on a
irradié ou à coquelles on injectait des
produits épouvantable là elle refuse de
faire les anesthésies
elle va pas changer d'opinion a ne va
pas changer d'attitude de toute façon
elles pensent qu'elles risquent la mort
et que de toute façon il ne s'en sortira
pas
miraculeusement adélaïde hautval et
oublier à birkenau et survit jusqu'à la
libération
elle reçoit la médaille des justes en
1965 et se suicide en 1988 car elle se
cette atteinte d'une maladie
dégénérative adélaïde hautval a choisi
son destin sans jamais trembler